[Música]
[Aplausos]
buenas tardes
voy a contar mi historia bueno cuando
era niña
56 años mi profesora siempre me llamaba
la atención en la clase en el jardín en
el colegio los primeros años del colegio
ya veces incluso me castigaban porque le
hacía las tareas mis compañeros
y en realidad esa no era mi idea porque
cuando estaba mis compañeros tratando de
hacer un dibujo y yo ya lo había hecho
siempre les ayudaba a hacerlo le estaba
explicando cómo se hace el dibujo y al
final quedaba tan parecido al niño que
la profesora siempre me pillaba decía
crédito castigada a la pared se acuerdan
antes unos lo castigaban mirando a la
pared y por un rato reflexionando sobre
que no debía hacer los dibujitos a mis
compañeros después como tipo 78 años me
regalaron una pizarra mi mamá me regaló
una pizarrita pequeña esas que se usaban
con tiza
y de hecho incluso en mi casa en ese
tiempo era de adobe y se cubría con tiza
no con tizas con yeso en realidad pero
quiero una materia prima ideal para
hacer piso y aprovechar mi pizarrita así
que siempre les enseñaba a mis
compañeras a veces venían cuatro o cinco
compañeras a que yo les explicaba
matemáticas
y ahora si miro hacia atrás en realidad
desde esos 56 78 años ya me encantaba la
enseñanza ya me gustaba enseñarle a mis
compañeros amaba la educación sin saber
que eso era el significado tan grande
que volvería que es la educación
esta mujer esta era mi heroína yo
recuerdo no sé si lo soñaba o lo veía en
la televisión en esa época con esta
mujer que enseñaba en escuelas rurales
con harto sacrificio y que niños también
hacían grandes sacrificios por llegar a
esa escuela harta fuerza harto empeño y
ella les transfería fortaleza y
esperanza de que ellos podían realizar
sus sueños
y mi sueño debe enseñar desde ese tiempo
ya era enseñar así es que
soñaba con enseñar bueno pero mi mamá
hoy
mi mamá a una mujer de muy fuerte
carácter algunos deben recordar a su
madre que también tienen fuertes
caracteres y hartas expectativas sobre
lo que ella quería de mí ella me dijo
sabes qué mejor oriéntate hacia la
contabilidad la contabilidad no tú yo
eres buena para las matemáticas y es un
sueño que yo no tuve además imagínense
me llama igual que ella las dos somos
verónicas así que está bien justicia y
con mi mamá diciéndome que es lo que
tenía que hacer un poco la verdad es que
me siento bien y yo ya los 13 años
estudiaron leseo técnico así es que ya
era contador cuando tenía 17 años
después empecé a estudiar en la
universidad
qué creen ustedes que estudie
contabilidad contador auditor así es que
pasé toda mi carrera mis estudios
universitarios de contabilidad y salida
de contador auditor también trabajé en
empresas por dos años en contabilidad
y luego en un momento cuando ya
trabajaba y no sé si les ha pasado a
ustedes que a veces uno tiene algo una
luz interior
la vocación como que te llama yo ya
trabajaba ya tenido un sueldo una
empresa bastante buena donde en la que
estaba en valparaíso porque yo soy de
valparaíso y tenía ya mi vida como
resuelta y la verdad es que eso que te
dice que quieres ir hacia donde tu
vocación te llama me hizo dejarlo todo
en ese momento dejé todo dejé mi trabajo
dejé obviamente mi sueldo y me fui
volver a vivir a la casa de mi mamá como
un estudiante nuevamente y comencé a
estudiar para poder enseñar y de ahí
comencé una carrera para enseñar en la
educación universitaria y aquí estoy
enseñando unos años más tarde comencé ya
enseñando en la universidad comencé a
hacer un proyecto con mis estudiantes un
proyecto en los que ellos se convertían
en asesores de pequeños muy pequeños
emprendedores el que hace el chocolate
la que hace arregla las vastas de la
ropa lo que hacen collares joyas
chocolate y pasteles etcétera en
realidad incluso para mí estudiantes los
que están en el primero de la lista
siempre son los de comida siempre son
los de copias porque ellos disfrutan y
es donde el emprendedor mirar su proceso
productivo que es hacer pancito que es
hacer tortas que haces chocolate y
siempre prueban algo por aquí por allá
así es que ellos en realidad les encanta
lo que es comiendo
y ese proyecto en realidad gracias a él
he descubierto qué
los estudiantes en realidad aprenden más
allá de lo que yo les explico en la
clase más allá de lo que les podemos
pasar en un libro ahí ellos asesorando a
emprendedores determinando los costos
porque yo soy profesora de costos
en realidad y aprenden desde la vivencia
desde la experiencia y aprenden con
emoción porque miran al emprendedor
miran el valor que ellos tienen el
empeño el esfuerzo la dedicación la
valentía por arrojarse un emprendimiento
ellos lo miran de cerca
y además incluso
ellos mismos aprenden haciendo este
trabajo comunicándose trabajando en
equipo en realidad para mí este es estos
proyectos este proyecto es maravilloso
en realidad yo lo encuentro maravilloso
yo llevo ya 10 años haciendo esto llevo
más de 1500 estudiantes que han pasado
por este curso y más de 500 empresas
pequeños micro emprendedores que hemos
asesorado ya llevamos todo eso y en
realidad no me terminó de sorprender
semestre a semestre
me emociono semestre a semestre como
ellos con qué dedicación lo hacen
incluso dura más de un semestre y son
cómplices a veces fui cómplice de hecho
una vez un uno de estos emprendedores
llegó a mi oficina muy enojado y yo
estaba haciendo algo me acuerdo y me
dice sabe que yo creo que es muy injusto
que usted le ponga está no también
estudiante
y usted por qué me dice eso usted mire
me dijo todo este semestre
estos chicos mis estudiantes porque son
suyos mis mi grupo o mis niños eso es ya
peor mis niños se han sacrificado todo
este semestre han entregado todo de sí
me han hecho un súper buen trabajo me
han enseñado a costear mis productos y
ustedes con esa nota bueno no quiero
decirles cuál fue el resultado de esa
nota pero les valga mirar bien lo que
ellos lograron hacer lo que ellos han
logrado hacer en el emprendedor como
mostraron eso yo en realidad creía que
eso que había visto yo era una instalen
o una marie curie porque juraba que
había descubierto algo muy importante en
la educación
y en el mundo pero la verdad es que eso
ya existía
eso se llama aprendizaje y servicio y el
aprendizaje servicio es cuando tú juntas
estudiantes y también a socios
comunitarios como se le llama en este
enfoque metodológico que nos para
nosotros son pequeños emprendedores los
juntas a todos en grupos y se vinculan
estudiantes con la comunidad y los
estudiantes aprenden sirviendo a la
comunidad enseñando pero la verdad es
que es una enseñanza mutua
enseña en experiencia los socios
comunitarios enseñan conocimiento pero
ambos en un equilibrio aprenden
mutuamente
eso es el aprendizaje y servicio una
metodología activa que aporta a la
educación para poder
en el estudiante dar el conocimiento
pero desde la vivencia desde la
experiencia ha sido ha sido diez años
maravillosos la verdad es que como les
digo semestre semestre me emocioné pero
no todo es color de rosa eso sí eso sí
han han habido momentos muy complejos
para mí porque uno a veces innovando o
mejorando o haciendo cosas distintas
haciendo cambios la verdad es que
siempre hay equivocaciones uno es ser
humano y de hecho ahí es descubrir lo
que es el costo de innovar porque
innovar es maravilloso
sí pero el día a día de innovar el ver a
los estudiantes y que los estudiantes a
veces no están tan satisfechos con lo
que uno hace y uno lo hace con toda la
entrega con todo el amor pero hacerlo
hace también hay que reconocerlo yo
partí enseñando con 30 alumnos en sala y
después tenía 60 70 alumnos en sala pero
ahí en estos 10 años he tenido las
peores evaluaciones de mis 20 años
de enseñanza
pero agradezco aunque igual agradezco
así pero agradezco el eso porque me ha
permitido reinventarme él me he dado
cuenta que uno no puede quedarse con una
innovación y dejarla ahí y que siga sino
que hay que permanentemente seguir
mejorando y esta evaluación que quizás
fue terrible para mí en ese momento me
impulsó a que yo tengo que ir mejorando
y para eso comenzamos no solamente yo
sino que gracias a la ayuda de hartas
colegas y que en realidad después se
transformaron en amigos que también
sufrían estas estas frustraciones o
estas estas desilusiones pero a su vez
amaba en esto porque venían los cambios
de los estudiantes empezamos a
investigar empezamos a ver cómo podemos
mejorar
rúbricas sistematización del curso
impacto de los estudiantes todo eso ha
hecho que investigar sea algo
fundamental para poder mejorar en la
educación para poder mejorar en el aula
incluso hace unos años atrás recuerdo
fuimos a una conferencia latinoamericana
de aprendizaje y servicios y vamos un
montón de chilenos más o menos eran como
60 de hecho vamos todos con las chapitas
o cities single l todas una chapita
maravilloso nos reconocimos y vimos en
realidad todos todo este gran grupo de
chilenos que nos encantaba este tipo de
metodología nos reconocimos y de hecho
la chapita decía que éramos de chile de
una red de aprendizaje servicio que a lo
largo del tiempo ha hecho grandes cosas
incluso este año hemos
por fin lanzado un libro digo por fin
porque se ha demorado un poco el libro
pero lo lanzamos por fin este año y es
el libro sobre la historia del
aprendizaje servicio y ahí encontramos
evidencias sobre lo que es el
aprendizaje y servicio en chile- y todo
y cada uno en sus instituciones años
generando evidencias y resultados y con
esos resultados cada vez hemos ido
mejorando y mejorando en nuestra aula
como transmitimos los conocimientos a
estudiantes cómo podemos entregar no
solamente el conocimiento como les dije
en el aula web o el material sino que
también en la experiencia y este este
libro fue en realidad un orgullo una
emoción para todos nosotros porque
imagínense en la historia de 17
universidades que se han unido a
escribir sobre la historia del
aprendizaje y servicio en chile y ahí
uno ve como nuestra aula el aula del
docente que era privada donde uno hacía
innova se convierte en pública
entonces con esto investigar en la
educación investigar en lo que yo hago
en mi sala me permite hacerlo
público y que todos los demás puedan
opinar y aportar a mejorar en mi aula
yo lo encuentro maravilloso y también
descubrí que eso que encuentro
maravilloso y todo lo que les he contado
hacia atrás tampoco yo lo inventé eso se
llama soto que es scholarship of
learning and teaching
y en esto la educación perdón la
docencia en el aula
es mi foco en mi caso junto con la
investigación
camina en armoniosamente
la investigación en mi caso está al
servicio de mejorar la docencia
y esa docencia es mi foco y esta
investigación tiene sentido para mí yo
muchos años estudie hice investigaciones
en mi área en contabilidad la
transparencia en el mercado los bonos el
efecto de las normas internacionales en
las empresas etcétera los activos los
pasivos
pero esa es esta investigación hoy día
que tiene que ver con mi estudiante con
cómo mejoró cada semestre en el aula no
tiene precio para mí en realidad es
valiosísima y cumplo en realidad con lo
que es importante en una universidad en
una universidad la docencia y la
investigación son lo más importante
tienen que estar en equilibrio y en
armonía porque el objetivo de una
universidad es que nuestros estudiantes
sean mejores cada día entonces a través
de nuestra enseñanza en el aula con la
investigación como clave en realidad
podemos lograrlo como como docentes y
como comunidad porque es con este
enfoque de aprendizaje y servicio la
comunidad también se vuelve un formador
finalmente debo decirles que agradezco
agradezco a la niña que le llamaban la
atención y le decía no debes hacer los
dibujos de estos compañeros porque ya en
ese momento amaba enseñar agradezco
también a mi madre porque si bien me
orientó por decirlo de una manera hacia
la contabilidad agradezco que me lo haya
hecho porque en esto en sotro en
aprendizaje y servicio he podido enseñar
desde mi disciplina desde la
contabilidad hacer cambios y hacer
transformaciones no solamente en mi
estudiante sino que también en mí la más
transformada a la que más ha cambiado a
lo largo de estos años soy yo y estoy
muy agradecida por eso agradecía por
todos mis colegas quien me han ayudado
que me han inspirado y que han
compartido conmigo este camino de
enfoques metodológicos y de
investigación en el aula y también en la
universidad de chile porque las
universidades tienen más espacio creo
que da que alguien te dé un espacio para
innovar espacios para crear
es maravilloso qué más puedo pedir si en
el fondo es ido logrando mis sueños y
logrado mis sueños y alguien me lo ha
permitido y me ha dado me ha dado la
mano y me ha permitido innovar y
finalmente puedo decirles que yo es a
esa niña pequeña ama enseñar muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]